this is the talent travelers Pig Doug I
just wanted to say people make mistakes
and you shouldn't hold that against him
there's about twincest isn't it
maybe aah God God before he could even
lay it um I'm sorry I broke you you know
you you missed it after the camera went
off he's like God Internet what the fuck
else work is exact work well but now we
have a pig involved so nothing more
crazy can come wet pork cest
I'm sure why you think I should mess up
with like Mabel and waddles or something
like the pork zest is like shredded
bacon like the zest of bacon aah
anywho uh this is not HG Wells prude is
the the code at the end of this one and
this is about time travel with one my
favorite layouts of a time machine the
measuring tape oh yeah that was reduce
well I that's so clever um so this time
traveller goes back in time from the
year was a 20-7 dear son looking funny
said evans nieven easy um but it was it
was a little like SN toe or that that
little Spanish yeah above a0 so makes it
when ya say yes 7 says me yeah yes no
yes yeah the time traveller goes back in
time and obviously played by the guy who
did lemma go we shot after uh obviously
done by the guy who did Lemongrab from
adventure time it again just clear
evidence these people watch Adventure
Time and want to do something similar
but like it's still something I'm not
complaining I think you can get you
fixed
no no it's bad - I don't care - there
are a couple times where Adventure Time
doesn't first but we'll get to those
when we get those um but uh he generally
hears it he travels back in time uh to
stop these people doing these anomalies
and of course it's gonna be different
Abel and dipper accidentally hits Wendy
in the eye of resulting in robbing the
day with her so he wants to travel back
in time and stop that but no matter what
everything is working against him to
make this happen there's one missing
equation it turns out it's Mabel winning
the pig waddles is the first appearance
of waddle
and so I love waddles already I'm just
like I love this thing he has so much
character um you hate waddles
I don't hate waddles we will get to
waddles again second I am still talking
about the story um fuck story waddles ah
you totally knit now I'm thinking I'm
I'm really like Mabel I just like why do
you say that we're Maybelle Mabel say
Mabel no say Kuwait cool quip say cool
whose elf that's cool
Connie re-enacted joke Oh sir what
whatever causes you the most pain say
twincest twincest well when you say like
that you make it sound cute it's
adorable tokens of lately derailed this
whole autumns um so Caillou did the cool
cuddles okay so they go back in time
dipper eventually realizes that he wants
to save waddles from a faith with
Pacifica Northwest to help his sister
out yes
and so they have to stop so he
eventually quote uncle gets Wendy I'm
obviously not gonna date him or anything
but gets to spend the day with her and
Mabel doesn't get to win waddles and he
goes whatever a month into the future
and see she's still there banging her
head against the totem pole so he
decides to go back and set everything
right so that waddles is to with Mabel
or Maybelle um the best and and
everything is said happily ever afters
that for the most part you know
dipper of course makes a sacrifice but
um I'll tell you though the thing I love
most about this episode uh aside of
waddles cuz we almost love waddles oh I
don't hate waddles God um he did it to
me too like it was some sort of secret
he wants to keep from you guys no I okay
just I I took I don't okay know what
waddle is I don't get balls like you
literally and hush watch the walls maybe
listening
whatõs is Momo from Avatar like he's
there's nothing wrong with him but it's
like you hey Momo - don't I don't hate
Momo bitching there's no personality to
him at all it's that there you might as
well just have a doll there like it's
Mabel's connection to waddles that is
what's fun about the waddles himself
doesn't have much to him there's like
one episode where they've done a lot
with him and even then it was like just
a story it wasn't like a real episode
why do you hate all of God's creatures I
don't just watch
I think do it you outed me I told it but
know what else is fine I just wish they
would do more with him like give him a
little bit more like Appa somehow has
more personality than waddles and I
don't know I can't explain how or why or
whatever but just kind of does yes he
appreciates that I I appreciate and go
hold on to him now because he's my Appa
and yeah anyway now this is a really
good episode I do sit about every
episode really most of them they're
they're all good I do really like uh
when I went into the far future with
tar-baby bad eye that's one of the
things I was gonna point out time baby
does come back and what what is know
what I love is that what I never
realized is that you kind of see the
origin of time baby there cuz he does
come back in the future and like you
just seem like destroying the city like
oh so that's how that happened so it's
one of those things where it's like cuz
I kind of forgot about a way comes back
as I was just certified like oh okay
whatever the time baby whatever that was
just like oh my god you actually see how
he got to that position so I'm all over
that I want more time baby you tease me
with time baby I need more I wet my beak
with time maybe I adore um when they go
to forget Leto in the very opening like
I start laughing early at a joke which
it's like you don't get yet to get to
the end where it's like they rigged the
the thing that dumps the grunkle Stan
and Audia with - here go pace these fake
safety uh yeah put your balls on the
suit yeah
Oh particular the ones that look like
you know a lawsuit liabilities he says
there
nothing can break this except maybe some
sort of futuristic armband laser that be
shot at it or something and that is
exactly whatever and when he said that
in the opening I just started laughs and
I'm like oh my god what a one ingenious
joke because you really nobody would
laugh at that unless you see it twice
like they just okay what a weird thing
to say whatever and that's exactly what
happens um the the Torrens tight jeans
aren't cool sorry should let you know no
they they they've never been cool I
think the only thing I didn't like again
I'm just like what is this kid's
obsession with Wendy who dipper dipper
yeah I know Robbie's a jackass oh yeah I
am
it's it's fit just I don't know young
love whatever oh I know I look at it I
don't hate her character but I'm just
like she's all right I probably feel
about Wendy the same way you do about
waddles and tunnels yeah yeah I mean I
just didn't they I would like if they
made her more she's a cute she's like a
cute character design without a lot of
real character attached to me yeah my I
would like it more if they play on busy
internet obsession cuz I'm like oh cute
girl character design like the next
thing you know means but like when it
comes to a actual character like yeah
like pretty much every line of dialogue
is like yeah that's cool up hey off the
June or yeah yeah it's like and when
they play that I am a mr. catchphrase
when they play anything this is gonna
sell something I don't know when they
play up sort of the slacker Ella the
slacker slash frat girl thing lately
said that stuff can be funny um but yeah
I wish they would have had more care no
I feel like I know
Zeus better than I do wouldn't he well
you do I mean that they don't but
they're saying he's obsessing over her
that much and I thought they would have
developed more to her but like right now
at least at this stage in the game she's
just the object of his affection yeah
she's kind of the pre nice I mean and
it's like I said which is one of those
things where it's like it's not my
favorite part but she's yeah
was it she she's an awful just omit all
that some sort of feminist argument
because I think there's other
interesting female characters in the
show it's just for some reason that's
not her
and yet he's there devoting so much time
to making her the objects like I just
wish they would have fleshed her out a
little more so maybe they will I don't
know that they have there's one or two
moments where I'm like okay that was
like a really cool
Wendy moment do you know but there's not
any of cool Wendy moments but yeah it's
at there's not that many like she seems
to be almost like just again with the
background character yeah like kind of
the prize you know um it's supposed to
be just as very safe you know character
that dipper can go to and have a loss
for and stuff like that but yeah I agree
I wish they did do more with the
character but yeah okay not bad you know
just would be nice no I don't hate um
that that's the thing I actually want
moreover as an actual character the
first two things I've noticed in this
one uh you'll know the the signal the
top-hat triangle the eye you see at the
beginning of every episode this is the
first time you actually see like that
exact image on the back of a playing
card it's actually I want the cards uh
but which honestly I don't think leads
baby Fae but it's just still addressing
that's there um then what did you
mention it well throughout the whole
show Kate and this is something every
dude knows until watching it like there
are triangles and it's something similar
to that image all over the place um but
that was the first time yet you see the
top hat and like the hand stuff like
that on the back of a playing card um
sounds kind of interesting I don't know
if that's like a huge thing layer but
the triangle does show up all over the
place and then the two future guards are
the the time cops like a bear term um I
love other names are oh yeah wolf and
dungeon uh or dungar that was very very
funny um and they come back to actually
so the triangle thing is on the playing
card yeah the actual I and the and the
top hat this time the triangle if you
look is actually all over the place and
sometimes with the I - I feel like
you're dipper and I'm Mabel Sisson I
like triangles yeah cuz I'm just sitting
here like there was a triangle in this
show like I've missed all of that it
looks like now if you look at this plain
guy this is triangular only cuts I'm
watching it again
um but off Dungan thing I actually would
have been because don't we love first
so subtle look at the names on their
uniforms I'm like thanks Doug that's
right and the botted like it was pretty
obvious I could have gotten that one
well well you didn't notice the
triangles I'm sure I don't call my than
you are it's maybe cuz I just want to
enjoy the show
calmer than you um that lengthen the
fucking gun around me it's just know
that the one part of us can talk about
before it really that I like which I
thought was a perfect combination of
being really funny and really touching
is when he does go to the future and
she's still there banging her head and
stuff that's really funny but at the
same time yeah you do feel the
connection she had and gets a passing
thing obvious as hell morals the sort of
thing that yeah there any other kids
show you'd be like ah but the way they
executed like when they Google all the
way like a month into the future and she
still hit in the head and here's the
little girl whose heart was completely
crushed by some heartless jerk
oh hey depper like it's the execution of
these jokes that make these morals
really really sweet and I like the fact
that that's a cyclic Runkle say it would
do he would just turn her into an
attract yes totally I will charge five
bucks out of whack so I mean if that was
both that was like a perfect combination
of really touching and really funny uh
and I love it when something can get
that down so perfect um so I really the
only missed opportunity was and I mean
this is what happens but they probably
just weren't planning this far ahead but
had they planned ahead enough I would
have actually inserted little sounds or
everybody yeah on the background of
previous episodes you could watch the
first seven or eight episodes and be
like oh shit I think I just spotted them
and I have it all connected III kind of
Italy because the second time arrived
been looking for little things in the
background said I didn't see them I
could have missed them but I don't think
they animated them in oh yeah I mean
that would have been amazing yeah and
what about really well maybe if maybe
they could do that again in some future
season or something I mean they are
ignorant like I said I mean maybe they
probably are doing a lot of stuff that
were not noticing I even on the second
viewing me um but yeah so no I I was a
pretty solid don't sit there in
scribbling
on some piece of paper when I die I do
take not be like forget I made a head
and I was gonna burn it
so Oh good episode um next one one of my
favorites uh fight fighters I think it's
always called the street fighter episode
so definitely looking forward to that
one and we'll see you there